you have a show a brand-new show you're
out promoting it and this is a big deal
for you you're going all out yeah it's
true I'm told you handed out free copies
on VHS by the side of the road is that
true that is very true I think we have a
picture here I love my my buddy Daschle
mm-hmm had the idea to go out and just
give out copies of the pilot on VHS
however legally we couldn't put copies
of the pilot on the VHS so if you got
one of the tapes you should know that
it's just me talking about why I don't
think we went to the moon for like 15
and by the way yeah I don't and you
should know that every time we land it
was under the Nixon administration huge
red flag here's the thing yeah that does
sound like a crazy personal drive right
but I think it's a thing that we just
accept and we just believe because it's
easier to get through life just
believing it you know like believing
like it's like believing your
grandparents really loved each other
[Laughter]
let's be honest okay if we can okay
your grandmother was in a loveless
marriage yeah
with a guy who at best was emotionally
distant at worse we don't want to get
into that yeah and and she stayed
because she didn't have a Beyonce song
to tell if she could do better
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Rudy Vallee wasn't singing about that I
wasn't thinking about that who has
girlfriend like stand by your man well
nothing happened that yeah I was just
standing it even if it was loveless hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography